hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again like
as usual we really don't have much to
talk about today but I do have a
discussion that I really want to talk to
you guys about and real quick I will be
streaming I believe today yeah today's
Thursday so on Friday tomorrow and then
Saturday the day after and then on
Sunday is gonna be my birthday so we're
gonna be doing three streams on Twitch
back to back to back hopefully we're
gonna begin that twitch affiliate
program started but yeah we're gonna be
streaming about three days in a row
streaming so for honor on Twitch I will
post a video when I do stream that and
you can always join my desk card for the
updates on that I would be highly
appreciated if you guys come by at least
say hi and stuff like that and drop a
follow and stuff but as always let's get
started with today's video first up
we're gonna talk about the news and
that's gonna be that there's a new
arcade quest as usual there's going to
be a challenge but the most takedowns
perfection will win that type of
challenge you're gonna get a beginning
some steel crates stuff like that and
then there's also going to be a sale
where there's gonna be 25% off of every
item so every item for every character
anything that is within foreigner is
gonna be 25% off and champion status is
gonna be 50% off as well and you compare
that with a double xp coming soon so
definitely be on the lookout for that
and then lastly there will be no weekly
streams on for honor anymore they want
to save the streams for bigger stuff
like the reveal on the 25th for an
example but starting in August and I
believe going up until October as of
what this roadmap says as you can see by
the picture everything with the Warriors
then logo will have big news possibly
and then the other stuff is going to be
small balance changes or things not
really worth an entire stream I don't
really mind this since I really find it
annoying waiting 30 minutes in a stream
to get really nothing eventful like
we've had the past couple weeks and
that's pretty much it for today so let's
talk foreigner in my opinion is at a low
point if not the lowest point we've had
so far from a content creator
perspective there really isn't much to
do and upload gameplay channels like
Kenzo splice toxic and flux can still
make content because their gameplay and
they don't really need on they don't
really have to wait weekly to do this
stuff but talking to some of them it
just seems very stale and boring just to
constantly keep doing employing these
characters and not really getting
anything out of it but from a news
perspective like me raven and infinite
and some others if i happen to miss them
it's very shitty
as you can tell there really isn't much
energy in my voice or any enthusiasm or
even in the content within the videos
aren't great because really isn't
anything to say this has always been the
case the start of the season and even
before the season starts with all the
teasers and the leaks it's loads of
content and it's super hype after the
season releases we go for a little bit
of an off break we don't really get too
much in the next following week since of
the biggest patch that they release for
the season and then maybe some small
content of the week here and there and
then the event comes out and then after
that it's back to the low point again
where there really isn't much because
the event ended and then we wait for the
teasers and it's just this constant
cycle of waiting for teasers waiting for
character gameplay the new season drops
then waiting for the event and then
rinse and repeat but I find this season
in particular to be the lowest point and
I believe it's for the fact of the main
reason of the character that released
the reworks that came out in the event
itself
he told Kerry in my opinion is very
boring to play I find her very
unenjoyable and not unique at all unlike
BP with his sword and shield and his new
bulwark mechanic hito kiri has a lot in
common with other characters and have
some variations as well like her sweep
attack which has variable timings like
other characters within the roster and
then comes the event which all you know
was not portrayed as well and shouldn't
have been portrayed that way everyone
knows that
III suck this year it's not a surprise I
enjoyed the event but not as much as the
past ones though and on top of that with
the removal of the weekly content we
haven't gotten one since it was over the
most hype thing according to my videos
and comments this season was the fact
that Raider kept getting nerfs and I can
totally see why and that's the other
thing many people were upset from those
reworks majority of the community
believes that Raider is too strong and
that law bringer really didn't go
anywhere with the rework this is isn't
completely true but is what the
community thinks and I'm just mentioning
it and my opinion Raider is really
strong but he's not too overpowered and
love burger did go somewhere with the
rework he definitely got a buff and he's
way better than what he used to be but
it wasn't a drastic change like the
Ken's a rubric or the concept of the
conquer rework that we got back in
season 5 with the struggle of those
reworks be it good or bad the new
character and the nice event
it really wasn't looking too hot for
this season and some of you who have
played a lot of foreigner can probably
hopefully agree with me that something
is definitely off this season as opposed
to last season in the ones
or it it kind of makes me worried about
next year if there will even be in next
year we still have got some time before
that happens and the devs haven't
actually told this if there will be a
year for the last time they did this
type of stuff is when we talked about
marching fire when marching fire first
released or was about to release they
mentioned on the big livestream that was
like four hours long that there will be
a year three which is the current year
that we're in so I'm expecting if we're
gonna be getting any teaser about year
for it'll be at the very end of of the
season 12 when the woollen character
comes out but that's just my idea and
what I assume that's going to be we're
just looking at the game I have this
really slight feeling that we may not
have another year and I'm hoping I'm
wrong cuz year four would be really
great but I don't know it just for some
odd reason seems that way let me know
what you guys think about this in the
comments below have you guys been
playing for on or a lot as recently I'll
be honest with you I used to play a lot
all the time almost every day and now
majority of the time I'm really just
trying to get game play and when I do
stream I don't really play off of that
usually I try it sometimes I go back and
maybe try to get some daily contracts
but other than that I'm not really
playing just to play in the middle of
the week
I'm like I said I'm usually doing it
just for background game play or if I'm
doing a stream with you guys and it does
kind of make me upset though I really do
wish that foreigner wasn't really in
this type of state that it is I can
totally understand why they would remove
the weekly content some of the stuff was
super boring and the whole meme with the
battle outfits we really didn't like
that so I can totally understand that
and I understand majority of the things
that they do on this stream why they're
not making weekly streams and why
they're going to be doing some streams
and some blog posts I completely
understand that just for it's more of a
quality of life change in a way but none
of this stuff has really happened in the
in with in the years of for honor and
just seeing all this stuff compiling on
together within the same season and even
in the same year it seems like we might
not have a year for I once again I'm
gonna be completely open about this I
don't actually know I really hope that
I'm totally wrong and I get completely
[ __ ] talked to the rest of my life about
thinking that we don't have one because
I really want a year for to happen and I
think a lot of people like you watching
the video well most likely one in year
four for this game because this game is
very unique in the Fighting's in the
fighting mechanics that it has and all
this beautiful stuff that it's given us
other than that like I said there really
wasn't
much in terms of news today the only
thing that we really got that super
exciting to look forward to it is the
big reveal on July 25th which is gonna
be showing us the season 11 character
the new Warhammer boy the one that
everybody's been hoping for it's
probably just going to be gameplay of
him and they might also show the new
reworks if there's going to be rubrics
there wasn't talked about that but there
hopefully should be but if they do show
that that'd be great if they just show
us the character I'll be fine with that
as well they'd like to be if you do
enjoy guys subscribed for a new I
covered the informational site or forint
that being the balance changes they hear
updates the patterns and the leaks if
you do want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
phoner and never miss out an update if
you say subscribe the channel and with
that guys have a great rest today and
take care
you